agoura 3rd investec Yuri Andreyevich is
a leading voice among intellectuals in
Ukraine is a novelist poet essayist and
a lover of the German language welcome
hello hello you're watching the DW
interview welcome I'm Alexandra phenomen
mr. Andrew kovitch you're known as a
dedicated European who has always
emphasized Ukraine's place in Europe but
when you look at the condition of the
European Union today do you still want
to be a member that's a onesie if I hope
not miss Clayton these include fan yeah
a little bit Ames oh yes definitely does
see snow to design an odd Swedish kite
obviously it's difficult for Ukraine
nothing Z after Ukraine has fought so
dramatically and so stoic Lee for its
European future leash to then be
confronted with a slightly different
reality and Evan alloted suit ref and
one slam it is a heart naked girl eated
a stubborn reality a [ __ ] that the
European Union is not an ideal structure
the destructor yet and it's a structure
that's facing so many challenges in
itself gasps mention it announced the
[ __ ] to such an extent if I helped you
believe is the one has to ask oneself if
it can't even survive fizzle to Karina
and it's at precisely this moment
toyline the Ukraine is dreaming of
becoming a member final meet me to yet
that's is the kind product even on but
nevertheless I believe this is a
productive time I can please what I mean
by that is the European Union is not a
union without any prospects at all so
absolute perspective flows
there are still societies that see the
European project as their chance for a
better future the accusation thorn
dissing her house for the onion the oil
patients probably spite all the
challenges you have better at souk
insane jeevana on telling the monster
you were amongst the demonstrators who
went out onto my dance square just under
two years ago calling for closer ties
with the EU how do you feel now when you
think back to that time and see the way
things are in Ukraine now do you feel
proud or disappointed from stones or the
air and toys on suemez own dish is thus
a disaster for me personally it's more a
sense of pride I don't regret taking
heart says I don't regret this whole
process that's why I can't leash I don't
regret all this time yeah it's the only
thing there was a real revolution of
dignity and it was also a sign that the
values that that are seen as the
foundation of being European oil patient
are still very much alive the z email
Okla been decent the sea so you can hate
us these values had such an effect that
millions of people were mobilized with
this popular uprising won't rotational
and should I ever write another novel
lunch Ivan I dreamed constantly about
writing one but I can't seem to get
started [ __ ] I would like the novel
to be about things like this sorted for
Island uses hola set sail can you think
of a particular encounter or seen that
you experienced the special deletes the
father this way done as well yes in the
last phase of the protests under my done
that's partially good site does it was a
really dangerous time
the most stunning get to that when the
first demonstrators were killed annoyed
too common and people were slowly
starting to move into a different mode
under a modus to come free to fighting
mode so to speak as fazal in one of the
counter musica gab and there was this
unknown musician who looked like he was
ready for war he was wearing camouflage
fatigues and a mask he wanted to call no
one could see his face same wound are
for the hear their outhouse and there
was an old piano standing in front of
the Kiev City Hall I todavia wouldn't
esas assets English pool and he sent
there quite often at this piano and
played music in Audi from imagine udo
vichu an Audi or John Lennon's Imagine
or Japan's revolutionary etude disposal
contrast for and there was such a bold
contrast between this very military
combative appearance and the brilliant
and beautiful music he played one and
for me he became like a symbol to a
certain extent of the whole thing it
wasn't a peaceful revolution
unfortunately there was a lot of blood
spilled a lot of fighting that was
filled blood she comes adorable party
okay did Europe let Ukraine down after
that when Russia annexed Crimea and when
the russian-backed separatists in the
east of the country went to war I didn't
click and [ __ ] my name I don't know
hotboy papa Alice get down in my opinion
Europe did everything that was possible
and it still is doing that today
hundreds I Ganesha the European Union
works primarily through diplomatic
channels and I think that's the right
way to do things because this whole war
argument is our responsibility now
that's the stores exactly it's Ukraine's
responsibility to build up its army and
increase its defense capabilities
fatigue one spot potential
ah so Europe can only be a diplomatic
and partner in this respect Europa come
here Noah so tagging and diplomatic soap
operas but what I do think is a mistake
that the West is made is the position of
NATO donato still as indecent in this
case it would have been a very good
preventive measure to stop Russian
aggression or at least is significantly
restricted if accession to NATO would be
considered for Ukraine there it did not
affect activist in Ukraine see getting I
thought you considered something of an
expert on Germany you've lived here you
sometimes recite your texts in German
and translate German poetry how did that
come about understand only door chimes
crap I'm Frank
mr. myner violence it wasn't my choice
at the beginning at the age of seven I
was sent to a school in Ukraine where
German was taught as a key disciplined
annoyed as the affiliate already said it
was a school with extra German lessons
initially me divided into it from 30 to
1 and we studied good as poetry to the
phone in fact by the age of eight or
nine yes one and we could already recite
some of his poems by heart Mancha else
finding it like I'd know his line for
example hide in the rest lanes freshman
I so does that work the same yarlung and
so that went on for ten years that's hot
yeah so I envision and that caused me to
start dreaming about the possibility I
see how that maybe one day I might be
able to speak to someone who was a
native speaker of German nithyanandam
digits oscillation at that time that
seemed totally impossible these are
practically smooches prophecies avoid US
team mission fantastisch house at the
end of the 1970s how each kind of movie
I had no chance of being able to visit
communist East Germany let alone West
Germany of course you buddy
bundesrepublik garnished so special but
times change deciding how easy to get in
that well done and the beginning of the
1990s I'm [ __ ] wasted yo cuz i was
able to come to Germany for the first
time for Adam I see a man today rd
beautiful Maria and I came then in my
status as someone who had translated the
poems of brine ammonia very good and so
there was this cultural bridge through
poetry into this world which was for me
above all to do with a language the
German language which I really liked a
lot hydroxamic she wouldn't want me to
feel until you've received many
international prizes German ones too now
you've just received the Goethe medal
for your work in promoting the German
language and the intellectual exchange
between Germany and Ukraine to Germans
really under
stand how Ukrainians think come Sean
saggin does devotion I have to say that
of all the nations in Europe the Germans
are the most open towards others in my
opinion often on the under east as a
doujin hobbies the Germans seek to
understand others or at least to show
interest what up in a significant
seminar yes what they want what they're
thinking the doulton was evolved acid
thinking one ish come out her second us
in Elena and I can see throughout the
course of my career how things have
changed that site and that so I nizar
it's one thing to talk about Ukraine in
1992 and quite another to talk about
Ukraine today it's the sea it's not
releasing of course more than 20 years
have passed since then he's been mean
I'm not unhappy I so he fended us I find
the Germany currently has a lot more
understanding and more awareness of
Ukraine and life in Ukraine he moment
get some justice today we always round
off the DW interview with three
open-ended sentences that I would ask
you to complete then you got talk to if
your daughter Sophia who is also a
writer would ask you to read her new
manuscript before it's published then
dun dun las then I would drop everything
and read it one sec are you happy that
she's become a writer too yeah yes
Houston Xena does not because she's my
daughter but because she's a brilliant
writer it's a great pleasure to read
anything new she's written Holies
phenergan that's personal useful yet so
lazy then it's just nice imagine the
next time I meet ukrainian President
Petro poroshenko I oh
damn good then I'll remain silent why as
a hobbit I can't leash because I have so
much to say that he would never have the
time to listen that's yeah [ __ ] notice
I haven't in 20 years Ukraine will be
yet Ukraine will be a member of the EU
mr. Andrew kovitch many thanks thank you
thank you